die eda freier ein tiefsee arbeitsschiff
besser geht's nicht ihr spezialgebiet
rohre verlegen das war ziemlich knifflig
bei bohrinseln auf offener see
aus sicherheitsgründen nähern wir uns
von der seite es ist wie ein
geschicklichkeitsspiel barkeit in 300
metern tiefe ich habe ein problem bei
dem es um millionen geht sicherheit ist
das a und o
ich habe familie
[Musik]
dieter frey ist ein arbeitsschiff der
offshore öl- und gasindustrie
sie verfügt über spezialkräne
ferngesteuerte unterwasserfahrzeuge und
riesige rollen für rohrleitungen
so kann sie die pipelines zwischen den
unterseeischen erdöl und erdgasquellen
und den bohrinseln erneuern
alle maschinen stopp
200 meter näher dürfen wir nicht an die
plattform rannten
[Musik]
die 1995 errichtete bohrinsel toll b hat
bis heute mehr als einer milliarde
barrel öl im wert von 30 milliarden
dollar gefördert
hier wartet der nächste auftrag auf
kapitän harald russland und seine
besatzung
50 meter steuerbord
65 kilometer vor der küste norwegens
befindet sich trotz eines der größten öl
und gasfelder in der nordsee
in den kommenden wochen werden unter
wasser wichtige leitungen bei zwei der
drei hier eingesetzten bohrinseln
ausgetauscht toll b macht den anfang
[Musik]
die besatzung der etwa frei muss dabei
strenge vorschriften einhalten
die sperrzone reicht von hier bis zur
plattform
wir dürfen uns der bohrinsel aus
sicherheitsgründen nur von dieser seite
die
etwa frei wird für den austausch und die
bergung eines sogenannten steigrohres
benötigt
in gut 300 metern tiefe werden öl und
erdgas von einer lagerstätte unter dem
meeresboden
zur verteiler basis gepumpt und von dort
durch flexible leitungen über einen
stützpunkt zur plattform befördert
wir müssen eine pipeline ersetzen weil
sie 20 jahre alt ist alle rohrleitungen
müssen nach einer gewissen zeit
ausgetauscht werden
bei der bergung des steigrohrs kommt
schweres gerät zum einsatz
ein offshore krank und ein spezieller
hebel turm mit vereinten kräften wird
das knapp 700 meter lange steigrohr am
meeresgrund an bord gezogen und
aufgeräumt also greifen und hoch
der betreiber statoil inzwischen teil
der firma equinet hat dabei ganz
besondere anforderungen
das heikle an diesem einsatz ist dass
während der arbeiten weiterhin öl und
gas gefördert werden
zum ersten mal überhaupt wird die etwa
fr an einer plattform arbeiten die in
betrieb ist
wir dürfen uns keinen fehler erlauben
die sicherheit hat zweimal voran aber
die produktion sollen nicht unterbrochen
werden
stadtmitarbeiter roger holzbrett weiß
dass das nicht einfach ist doch er hat
vollstes vertrauen in die hacker
fehlerfreie eignet sich perfekt für den
austausch von
150 meter lang 27 meter breit und mit
einer decke fläche von 2.300
quadratmetern viel wichtiger ist jedoch
was die eta freier unter der
wasseroberfläche zu bieten
in der mitte des schiffes befindet sich
ein großes loch auch nun touren genannt
durch das leitungen in die tiefen des
meeres hinabgelassen werden können durch
zwei kleinere moon tools können die
beiden ferngesteuerten
unterwasserfahrzeugen die awo wies zu
wasser gelassen werden
[Musik]
wir liegen im zeitplan und nicht anders
vorbereitet
das team auf der brücke hält das schiff
auf position die aws befinden sich im
hauptteil des schiffes
unterdessen bereitet john robertson den
start eines euro wie vor
wenn die logen offen sind wird das
herunter gelassen das geht auch bei
starkem sich
das erste der beiden der awo wies wird
in den zwölf meter tiefen pool abgesenkt
ohne diese fahrzeuge während solcher
einsätze und denkbar
die awo wies sind die augen und hände
der etwa freier unter wasser
sie haben acht kameras 10 scheinwerfer
und hydraulische arme mit 25
austauschbaren werkzeuge
[Musik]
mit ihnen können sie griffe dreh in
knoten machen und sogar senken
das team auf der plattform löst das
steigrohr
sie lassen jetzt das steigrohr und wir
beobachten das ganze mit etwas
näher zum meeresboden techniker robert
jezic steuert das erste a movie zum
meeresgrund um alles im blick zu haben
ich darf keinen satz aufwirbeln reich
sonst nicht sehen wo genau meine
position ist
[Musik]
auch das zweite a row wie wird versenkt
um seinen bruder am meeresgrund zu
unterstützen
65 kilometer vor der norwegischen küste
ist das arbeitsschiff etwa freier dabei
eine pipeline eine bohrinsel troll b zu
ersetzen
es handelt sich um ein steigrohr durch
das öl und gas von der quelle unter dem
meeresboden zur bohrinsel gelangen
wir bringen in der chef in position
rossini ist ein mitarbeiter der
unterwasser baufirma die puschen die das
projekt leitet
wir werden das alte steigrohr der trolle
und ersetzen ist durch ein neues 10 zoll
förder steigrohr hier sieht man
plattform und stütz bogen das ende vom
steigrohr wurde schon gelöst
das steigrohr wird mit hilfe einer
speziellen klemme am ende und eine
schlinge um die mitte geworden
[Musik]
brücke ausleger schwenkt aus mit dem
kran wird die riesige schlinge
abgelassen um das steigrohr damit zu
heben
ihre profis legen die schlinge um das
hohe
langsamer
das klingt einfacher als es ist
mit rechts steuere ich den master an er
macht was ich mache bei dieser frische
sind die piloten hans peter bjorn john
und robert yes it gefragt
okay
die arogis sind ihre augen und arme in
der tiefe
beim anbringen der schlinge steuert
roboter sowie und die kameras damit sich
alles gut im blick habe
jetzt steuert auf die schlinge zu und
panzern versucht sie zu greifen
[Musik]
wir fangen jetzt mit der ersten schlinge
an
wir wickeln die flexible schlinge
zweimal um das steigrohr
doppelt hält besser
die ansmann versucht die schlinge unter
dem rohr hindurch zu führen
von der anderen seite geht es besser ich
glaube
gegen den uhrzeigersinn genau
während eine ahnung die schlinge hält
zieht der andere sie unter dem rohr
hindurch die kameras exakt auszurichten
ist knifflig doch nur so sehen die
piloten was sie tun
kamera hoch bitte kamera höher
etwas zurück genauso
vielleicht von unten
ich komme nicht dran stimmt
gegen den uhrzeigersinn
an land wäre das ganze eine sache von
sekunden
jetzt einfach loslassen
etwas höher versuchs unter wasser ist es
jedoch mühevolle kleinarbeit
ein bisschen höher
ich gebe schon
etwas lockern aber nicht die schlinge
fallen lassen
nach einer halben stunde ist die
schlinge um das steigrohr fixiert
[Musik]
danke
für ihr seht und ganzen gibt es keine
verschnaufpause
als nächstes müssen sie die spezial
klemme vorbereiten die das ende des
rohres greifen wird
das ist das hydrauliksystem zum öffnen
der klemme
deaktivieren wir jetzt
dass erwin stöpselt die hydraulikleitung
1 dann ist die klemme einsatzbereit
jetzt entwickeln wir noch die
mechanische sperre
und zwar im uhrzeigersinn
die klemme öffnet sich so weit es geht
um das pendel des steigrohrs zu fassen
nach 20 jahren in der tiefsee hat es
seinen dienst getan
dann wird die klemme verriegelt und die
hydraulikleitung entfernt
sie lösen die haken des euro wie
die klemme ist fixiert
jetzt lösen wir die haken von den hebel
das sind diese beiden hier
sieht gut aus
die schwerstarbeit übernimmt ein
spezieller hebel turm das sogenannte
vertikale system kurs wls
wir bergen das alte steigrohr nun mit
dem hebel toren und wickeln das dann auf
eine rolle auf
[Musik]
mit hilfe des cls zieht dieter frey ein
ende des steigrohrs hoch während das
andere ende mit einem führungs seil von
der öl plattform verbunden bleibt
das hier ist die große motor luke unser
direkter zugang zum meer
us-fans überwacht die vorbereitungen für
das einholen des steigrohrs
das ist das stahlkabel des turms das
wird auf dem meeresgrund runtergelassen
um das rohr hochzuziehen
wir bereiten alles vor und öffnen gleich
die klappe öffnet
[Musik]
sich
der große ruhepol gibt den blick auf die
wellen frei
dann wird der strahl zeile in die see
abgesenkt muss mit der klemme am ohr
verbunden wird
ab nach unten damit die rollen dienen
als führung damit nichts beschädigt wird
damit die feier
[Musik]
das steigrohr hebt sich vom meeresgrund
zutaten das rohr ist 690 meter lang und
wiegt 140 tonnen
gesteuert wird der kran vom kranführer
haus aus könnte einer von euch nach oben
gehen um die exakte höhe vorzugeben
der wrs führe mix king bittet seine
kollegen um hilfe von oben
wir haben von hier oben eine ganz gute
sicht auf den mond manchmal sehen wir
mehr als die da unten
gleich steigt noch einer auf den turm
aus der vogelperspektive genaue
anweisungen zu geben
das schwere gerät bedeutet ein hohes
risiko für die besatzung
sicherheit hat vorrang wir wollen alle
heil nach hause kommen
[Musik]
ich kontrolliere ob die takelage richtig
justiert ist der wls turm ist mit einer
reihe von greifern spannvorrichtungen
ausgestattet damit das rohr kontrolliert
wo gezogen werden kann
wir ziehen es so weit hoch dass die
abstandshalter für stabilität sorgen die
korrekte spannung ist entscheidend zu
wenig und es verrutscht zu viel und es
wird beschädigt
weil das steigrohr durch den mittleren
moon pool gezogen wird bleibt das schiff
im gleichgewicht und das selbst bei
rauer see
das steigrohr wird über die spitze des
wls turms geführt und von dort runter
aufs deck bis auf eine leere rolle
gespielt wird
16 stunden später wird das flexible rohr
immer noch aufgeholt hoch oben auf dem
gls turm hat aufseher steven taylor
alles genau im blick
bls anlagen werden vier unterwasser
versorgung steig und rück leitungen
eingesetzt weil sie ein kontrolliertes
arbeiten ermöglichen
vor 20 jahren war ich auf dem schiff
dass dieses rohr montiert hat
dieser teil war mit der bohrinsel
verbunden
geschafft das steigrohr ist nun komplett
an bord wir wollen dieses jahr noch
fertig auf und bereiten dann das neue
steigrohr fort
der erste teil der mission ist erledigt
das team fährt die riesige spann einheit
wieder ein
alles lief nach plan
niemand hat sich verletzt irgendwas
eingeklemmt was will man mehr
okay das recht nach 21 stunden können
die männer für einen moment durchatmen
doch am meeresgrund herrscht eine
gewisse unruhe
vor der ostküste norwegens hat das
tiefsee arbeitsschiff rea ein
ausgedientes steigrohr von der bohrinsel
troll b geborgen
nach oben nun montiert die crew ein
neuer steigrohr dass sie die nächsten 20
jahre halten sollen
zwei ferngesteuerte unterwasserfahrzeuge
d red affair sind in 300 metern tiefe im
einsatz und haben dort ihre liebe mühe
denn ihr licht zieht scharenweise
fischer hat das ist ein problem wegen
der schlechten sicht müssen die piloten
jan fress und martin erdl aufpassen dass
sie sich nicht verheddern
da die sicht bei diesen bedingungen
stark eingeschränkt ist müssen wir
besonders vorsichtig sein
karrubis sind sehr agil ihre
versorgungskabel sind gerade mal doppelt
so dick wie ein gartenschlauch
die kabel versorgen die awo wies mit
strom über hydraulikleitungen werden
scheinwerfer propeller und arme
gesteuert
außerdem überträgt das kabel
videosignale zum horror wie steuerpult
an bord des schiffs
ich komme von oben das ist einfach
dreist die steuert das army c6 und lehrt
all dessen bruder 25
ich muss mein kabel erst mal aus dem weg
schaffen damit ich dem c5 nachher nicht
in die quere kommen
das schöne gelbgrüne kabel verbindet c5
mit der eppa freyer
das ist das kabel von 25 ich muss rechts
rüber damit wir uns nicht verhindern
eine falsche bewegung und es für
zappenduster
wenn das kabel durchtrennt wird können
wir das auto wie nicht mehr steuern und
müssen es bei hagens
die crew lässt nun das neue steigrohr
runter
wir führen das ende des steigrohrs
gerade über unser bls system
je tiefer das rohr ins wasser ragt desto
größer ist die belastung auf das wls das
tempo wird mittels einer winde reguliert
die jungs bedienen die
spannvorrichtungen vom kontrollraum aus
wie diesen greifarmen können die männer
die geschwindigkeit bestimmt im
anschluss müssen wir das zugseil von der
bohrinsel aufnehmen
der wrs turm versenkt das neue steigrohr
in der nordsee
anschließend muss die kuh es in der
vorgesehenen führung des stütz- bogens
platzieren mit einem führungs seil wird
das ende des tages schließlich zur
bohrinsel talbi hochgezogen
da die umliegenden steig rohre
währenddessen öl und gas transportieren
muss die neue pipeline extrem behutsam
eingebaut werden brücke neuer kurs
siebenmeter 14 57 meter 14 5
das ist der schwierigste an dem ganzen
einsatz
siebenmeter 145
[Musik]
und der kran des schiffs führen dass
neue steigrohr mit konstanter
geschwindigkeit in die tiefe man sieht
hier die führungsschiene genau da muss
die anschlüsse linsler
[Musik]
dank der aro wie kameras hat die crew
alles im blick
davor ist noch nicht perfekt
ausgerichtet allein
sehen wie sie das jetzt hinkriegen
stopp nach 23 stunden und einigem hin
und her ist das neue steigrohr am
meeresgrund angekommen und auf dem
stützpunkt sie ziert wie alex stopp
danke
dieser teil ist immer nervenaufreibend
weil man fingerspitzengefühl braucht
die besetzung wird den ganzen nächsten
tag brauchen um das rohr an die
bohrplattform anzuschließen
auf der etwa freier wird rund um die uhr
gearbeitet
[Musik]
die audi piloten arbeiten in zwölf
stunden schichten
nach zwei wochen an bord wird die
besatzung mit hilfe von hubschraubern
ausgetauscht
[Musik]
das wetter war bisher ziemlich gut aber
jetzt schlägt s langsam
derzeit liegt der wind bei 30 knoten mit
zwei bis drei meter hohen
nach dreieinhalb tagen an der bohrinsel
troll b nimmt die epa freyer kurs auf
ihr nächstes ziel troll c
die 13 kilometer nordöstlich gelegene
bohrinsel fördert ebenfalls öl und
erdgas
dort muss unterhalb der plattform ein
spezial rohr geborgen werden das zur
sogenannten gas lift förderung verwendet
wird alle flexiblen pipelines müssen
nach 20 jahren ersetzt werden
bei der gas lift förderung wird neben
dem bohrloch gas ins speicher gestein
gepresst um dem öl mehr auftrieb zu
verleihen
doch bevor das injektions hoher geborgen
werden kann muss die gaszufuhr
abgestellt werden außerdem muss die
besatzung der edda fr das rohr von der
plattform trennen
dabei nutzt sie das einzugs und
verbindungs tool auch big tool genannt
luke ist offen damit das rohr
eingespannt und dann abgedreht werden
kann
[Musik]
das big tool muss exakt auf zwei
führungsposten an der verteiler basis
der plattform positioniert werden
sechs etwas weiter nördlich damit wir
die pfosten
im kontrollraum über dem droschken sp
die koordination zwischen der brücke
den aro wie piloten und dem kran führen
krahn etwas tiefer bitte bestätigen der
kran senkt und hebt das bistum
sind alle bereit während der kapitän die
position des schiffs anpasst
dritte kleine kurskorrektur 10 10 13 05
in der tiefe manövrieren die awo wies
das pic tool zu den führungsposten
soweit es toll an einem pfosten
eingerastet ist können wir es
entsprechend drehen damit es auch auf
den zweiten passt das weshalb sind die
posten unterschiedlich lang
krahn etwas team
die klemme des pools ist bereits
geöffnet
krahn etwas tiefer
sie richten das tool an den beiden
pfosten aus
es fehlt nicht mehr viel sie bewegen es
mit dem kran und mit dem schiff selbst
beide sind weit weg an der oberfläche
hier unten zählt jeder zentimeter
[Musik]
30 5 grad etwas hören
verstanden
röcke ein meter auf 1 20
auf 1
[Musik]
die männer brauchen viel
fingerspitzengefühl
asarow wie ist kurz davor das pic tool
auf den höheren pfosten zu setzen
es fehle nur wenige zentimeter doch dann
immer ich habe ein problem
[Musik]
vielleicht ein problem mit der spannung
gab voranmeldungen das euro vj ist
manövrierunfähig
die techniker müssen es bergan und
hoffen dass sich das problem leicht
behindert ist
c6 notfall tagung des
[Musik]
das arbeitsschiff etwa freyer führt
wichtige wartungsarbeiten an einer
bohrinsel in der nordsee durch
in 300 metern tiefe ist eines der
ferngesteuerten unterwasserfahrzeugen
ausgefallen ich habe ein problem der awo
wie pilot hat die kontrolle über den
tauchroboter verloren
die instrumente funktionieren sonst
hätten wir kein bild aber die hydraulik
und die elektromotoren streiken
sollen wir ihnen deck holen und
überprüfen
das aero wird mit einer winde an die
oberfläche hochgezogen und durch den nun
pool an deck tief
totalausfall der hauptmotor ist hinüber
nun muss die crew der edifier ganz auf
das zweite ersetzen
die besatzung auf der brücke hatte
ebenfalls sorgen der wind ist stärker
geworden michael kroll enco analysiert
die strömung seine aufgabe ist es wetter
wind und wellen stets im blick zu haben
aktuell treiben wir auf die plattform
sollte der schiffsmotor ausfallen könnte
die etappe auf die bohrinsel zu treiben
und mit den steig rohren kollidieren um
dem vorzubeugen muss der kapitän das
schiff umgehend neu positionieren
wir können erst weiterarbeiten wenn der
wind nachlässt oder sich die richtung
ändert weg von der brenz
solange der seegang so stark ist werden
die bergungsarbeiten unterbrochen
das pack tool wird wieder an bord
gehievt und das schiff wird auf die
andere seite der plattform so besteht
keine kollisionsgefahr mit den
steigerungen
die strömung ist zu stark also heißt es
abwarten
wir sind den windschatten und werden nun
die steigrohr mit dem euro wieder
unter wasser sind wind und wellen kein
problem deshalb wird die zeit sinnvoll
für andere arbeiten genutzt
[Musik]
ich wickle gleicht dieses band um das
rohr und machte es damit sauber
ich kratze den bewuchs weg indem ich es
auf und ab bewegen
im laufe der zeit siedeln sich allerlei
meereslebewesen auf den steige rohren an
das band schafft sie ab wie ein riesiges
stück zahn seite
keine hightech lösung aber es hat schick
und teuer wenn es auch so funktioniert
dass sie gut aus zwei stunden später hat
strömungs experte colenco gute
neuigkeiten das ist eine stark
vereinfachte darstellt
sollten unsere motoren jetzt ausfallen
würde das schiff in diese richtung
treiben also weg von der plattform
ovi hangar hat ausgehe herres weder
ebenfalls gute nachrichten
diese motoren laufen sonst 56 jahre ohne
probleme ein solcher ausfall ist selten
aber
zum glück hatten wir einen ersatzmotor
an bord den habe ich jetzt einfach
eingebaut
[Musik]
das remis ist wieder einsatzbereit
das big tool kann wieder an tauchen
wir sind fast auf den pfosten
bei der awo wies begleiten das big tool
um es auf den führungsposten zu fixieren
noch ein paar zentimeter
das tool sitzt auf dem langen pfosten
jetzt will es mit dem zweiten euro vj
auf den kürzeren fast manövriert
siehst du deinen kabel c 56 bitte nach
unten
nun wird das tool auf den zweiten
pfosten gesetzt
krahn etwas tiefer und
tiefer ja
dennoch eine meter
aufgestockt
das pack tour des erst in position
mit hilfe des pic tools trennt die crew
das injektions rohr von der verteiler
basis dann kann es gebäuden werden
durch dieses spezial rohr wird gas in
das bohrloch gepumpt damit über die
staig rohren leichter öl gefördert
werden kann
an einer stelle verläuft das rohr unter
einem anderen hindurch anstatt des
herauszuziehen wird dieser bereich
abgetrennt und zurückgelassen die beiden
frei liegenden teile werden an bord
geholt
wir schneiden das injektions rund einer
diamantsäge durch und zwar links und
rechts der stelle wo die rohre
aufeinander liegen
die beiden teile bergen wir dann separat
nachdem der gashahn zugedreht wurde
das ist quasi eine hydraulische absägen
bereits arbeitet für cutting the water
technologies kurz kath
die säge verfügt über einen diamant
verstärkten draht der von zwei rollen
angetrieben wird
unterwasser klappt diese rolle nach
hinten
dann kommt das war hier in die mitte wo
es mit diesen beiden greifarmen festigen
während das ohr wie c6 die säge zum
grund des meeres befördert
ist c5 bereits dabei den bereich um das
rohr frei zu legen damit die säge gleich
korrekt platziert werden kann
wir graben quasi ein kleines loch die
säge aber wir haben keine schaufel
sondern eine art staubsauger der den
schlamm einsaugt und auswirkt
wenn das rohr freigelegt ist beim c6 die
säge an bringen und es kann losgehen
wir sitzen hier eine dm anträge ein weil
die leitung unter einem anderen
steigrohr legt
wenn wir den bereich herausgetrennt
haben werden beide eltern geworden
die crew arbeitete nahezu blind
da so viel schlamm aufgewirbelt wird
müssen sie sich auf ihr gefühl verlassen
wir schneiden die säge aus und versuchen
zu sehen ob das wort wenn das nicht
funktioniert
sagen wir so lange bis das rohr nach
unten fällt dann wissen wir dass wir
durch sind
[Musik]
na also
wir sind durch
doch beim zweiten schnitt
herzlich verkeilt zurück
jetzt noch einmal die säge hat sie
festgefressen
das könnte für die crew einen langen
nacht werden
in den tiefen der nordsee steckt das
team der ida frei buchstäblich in der
klemme
beim durchtrennen einer pipeline hat
sich der diamant rat der unterwasser
säge verkeilt dass
es mit dem manipulator im kontrollraum
des tiefsee arbeitsschiff versuchen
techniker white und aro wie pilot fress
ii die serie wieder in gang zu bekommen
der draht hat sich verkeilt wir ziehen
die säge ein stück hoch schauen ob sie
läuft und versuchen ist ein
[Musik]
vorgang unterbrechen bestätigen
fresst sie versucht den draht mit hilfe
der roboterarme zu lösen
ich war jetzt ein bisschen hin und her
um den draht freizubekommen
wenn das nicht geht müssen wir den
schnitt aufgeben und in rath erneuern
die säge lässt sich von dem kleinen
schubs leider nicht beeindrucken
versucht die säge nochmal zum ovi zu
ziehen
ok daumendrücken nichts
tut sich
drei mal warum nicht
sie konnten die säge befreien doch
wahrscheinlich ist der säge draht
beschädigt
wir werden jetzt den draht austauschen
das euro vj und die säge werden wieder
an bord geholt
white hofft dass kein größerer schaden
einige stellen sind kaputt weil wir an
der säge gezogen haben
diesen draht können wir jetzt leider
nicht mehr verwenden
das ist erneuert und jetzt montieren
einen dritten hätte ich noch aber wir
hoffen jetzt mal das beste
[Musik]
größte auftauchen das aroma und die säge
erneut ab
es ist durch das rohr hat sich bewegt
wir haben jetzt vier uhr 16
geschaffen beim zweiten versuch hat es
geklappt
der zweite schnitt war erfolgreich
[Musik]
zehn stunden später braucht sich in der
tiefe ein neues putin zusammen
wir kämpfen gerade ein wenig mit unserer
klemme sie lässt sich offenbar nicht
richtig steuern
die klemme zur bergung des rohres lässt
sich nicht montieren
die klemme soll das forum fließen und
fixieren bevor wir sie
[Musik]
niemand weiss weshalb die klemmt es war
nicht greifen kann auch die kamera
bilder geben keinen aufschluss darüber
[Musik]
wir müssen die klemme bergen und ihr
testen
vielleicht ist sie verdreckt dort besser
dafür schneiden sie ein kleines stück
rohr ab
und holen es nach oben
jetzt wissen wir warum es nicht geklappt
hat
das problem ist offensichtlich die
klemme ist zu klein für das injektions
rohr
der außendurchmesser des rohres ist
leider fünf millimeter größer als
erwartet
da das team keine andere klemme hat muss
es diese hier anpassen
doch dafür muss die etwa freier wichtige
ersatzteile besorgen
[Musik]
ja
im hafen der norwegischen stadt bergen
haben techniker die ganze nacht
durchgearbeitet
im nu sind die neuen teile an der klemme
montieren
sie passen perfekt aber das ist noch
keine garantie dass die klemme jetzt
funktioniert
[Musik]
wir schließen die hydraulik an dann
führen wir mit der klemme einen test
durch
die männer müssen sichergehen dass die
klemme unter dem gewicht des
tonnenschweren rohres nicht nachgibt
wir testen das jetzt am 2 aktuell sind
wir bei 24 tonnen die tragfähigkeit
sollte bei 30 tonnen liegen
denn wir sind jetzt bei 27 tonnen
etwas jedoch
ok bleibt so
die klemme hält
sie hat den test bestanden bei der
belastungsprobe waren es 31 tonnen
die jeder frei an nimmt wieder kurs auf
trolley
stadtteil mitarbeiter roger holzbett
weiß dass jede sekunde zählt
hoffentlich hält das wetter damit wir
das injektions ruhe an bord holen können
nun sind die piloten erneut am zug sie
sollen die käme sicher am rohr
befestigen
[Musik]
wir versuchen es jetzt nochmal mit den
neuen greifen und hoffentlich klappt es
noch 15 meter bitte
15 meter die klemme umgreift das rohr
frisst sie sitzt bolzen ein um sie zu
verriegeln
jetzt ist sie geschlossen
[Musik]
nun ist das bärtige live system
gefordert meter für meter zieht es das
rohr über die turmspitze auf der anderen
seite läuft das rohr durch eine führungs
vorrichtung auf die letzte freie rolle
an bord
auftrag ausgeführt
mit einem guten team ist dieter frey er
unschlagbar
die besatzung der edda freyer hat ganze
arbeit geleistet
sie hat wichtige pipelines in zwei
höhlen und gas förderplattformen
erneuert ohne dass die förderung
unterbrochen werden musste
3 2 1
[Applaus]
alle sind zufrieden
viele von uns sind schon ein paar wochen
hier draußen
jetzt freuen wir uns darauf unsere
familien zusammen
doch für die eder freier geht die reise
weiter
mit einer frischen crew und einen neuen
auftrag
[Musik]